GAUDREAU, MONAHAN WORKING IT
AROUND.
HUDLER IS THE OTHER OF THE
FORWARD.
MONAHAN SLIDES IT DOWN LOW.
GAUDREAU MOVING UP.
HAMILTON OVER AT THE LEFT POINT.
PUCK COMES OUT TO HIM.
UNDER A BIT OF PRESSURE.
FROLIK.
HERE'S RAYMOND AROUND.
NOWHERE TO GO.
LONG PASS UP AHEAD.
RAYMOND MOVING IN.
WILL HE GET A SHOT?
TANEV CRACKS IT UP TO THE
CORNER.
HENRIK SEDIN ALL THE WAY UP
AROUND TO A WAITING DANIEL.
BACK OF THE NET.
SUTTER LOOKING, TWISTING,
TURNING, FINDS SOME ROOM.
TRIED TO GO HIGH.
THE BACKHANDER MISSED.
[CROWD NOISE]
>> Paul: FIRST POWERPLAY OF THE
GAME FOR VANCOUVER.
HUTTON WORKS IT ACROSS.
BAERTSCHI SLIDES IT DOWN LOW.
BAERTSCHI HUSTLING BACK TO PICK
IT UP.
>> Mike: MISSED OPPORTUNITY.
HE ELECTED TO GO TO HAMHUIS ON
HIS FOREHAND.
COULDN'T ONE-TIME THE PUCK.
>> Paul: PUCK PUNCHED BACK IN.
SUTTER GOING FOR THE FRONT.
HENRIK IS OVER ON THE WEAK SIDE.
WEBER WAS BACK THERE ON THE BLUE
LINE.
BRIDGED TOO FAR.
HE TRIED TO STRETCH.
COULDN'T QUITE GET TO IT.
GIORDANO.
TAKES IT BACK UP AND AROUND.
BAERTSCHI WHEELING UP THERE.
KNOCKED IT DOWN.
COULDN'T CATCH UP TO IT.
HAMILTON GOT IT UP AHEAD.
GAUDREAU DROPPED IT OFF THERE.
FROLIK DRIVING IN.
HE MAKES SURE TO GET THE RUBBING
UP TO THE RED LINE.
AFTER THAT FIRST TURNOVER,
WILLIE DESJARDINS SHAKING HIS
HEAD, NOSE WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
THAT.
>> Paul: MONAHAN, NICE, NICE.
GETS IT UP IN FRONT.REENFORCED
THAT IT'S A VETERAN THAT REALLY
ESTABLISHES THAT CHARACTER, THAT
CULTURE OF A TEAM.
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE SEDINS
HERE, HOW TO BE ACCOUNTABLE AND
UNSELFISH AND TEAM FIRS
SBISA HUSTLING UP THERE AFTER
IT.
HORVAT TWISTING, TURNING, FIRES
IT ACROSS BURROWS WHO'S
STREAKING IN FROM THAT RIGHT
SIDE.D LOTS OF ROOM, A BIG STAGO
SHOW OFF THOSE SKILLS.
AND NO ONE HAS A BIGGER SET THAN
HENRIK SEDIN.
WORKS IT ACROSS.
TANEV.
HENRIK GETS IT UP.
LOOKS AROUND.
FLAMES GET IN A CHANGE.
WIDEMAN COMES OFF THE BENCH.
HUDLER DROPS IT BACK.
GAUDREAU.
POCKET PICKED.
COULDN'T GET AWAY.
GAUDREAU IN.
SCORES!